nos dicen observan los números reales a
continuación ordena los del menor al
mayor aunque esta parte como que está
además no tenían que decirnos que son
números reales nos dan un medio menos 5
3.30 21 sobre 12 menos 5.5 y los enteros
un octavo quizás la forma más fácil de
visualizar estos números es dibujando
una recta numérica y colocándolos en
ella esta recta debe ser lo
suficientemente larga para contener a
todos estos números y así podamos
comparar los vamos a dibujar una recta
numérica bien grande aquí
bueno vemos que tenemos unos números
negativos por acá y llegamos tan abajo
como menos 5.5 también tenemos unos
números positivos por acá y llegamos tan
arriba como 3.3 esto de aquí es un
poquito menos de 2 así que yo creo que
puedo poner el 0 acá justo en el medio
aunque quizá un poquito más a la derecha
porque tenemos nuestros números
negativos un poco más grandes aquí
tenemos el 0 este va a ser menos 1 - 2 -
3 - 4 menos 5 y yo creo que con esto
suficiente en el sentido positivo vamos
a tener 1 2 3 4
ahora veamos este un medio donde lo
podemos colocar este se encuentra
justamente a la mitad del 0 y el 1 es la
mitad de un entero va a estar si aquí
tenemos un entero pues hasta un medio va
a estar justo a la mitad entre el 0 y el
aquí vamos a tener nuestro un medio
es lo mismo que 0.5 después tenemos el
menos 5 bueno si éste es menos 1 - 2 - 3
- 4 - 5 este va aquí
ahora tenemos 3.3 positivo aquí tenemos
123 y queremos estar en el 3.3 está más
o menos a una tercera parte del camino
entre el 3 y el 4 o un poquito menos que
la tercera parte ya que una tercera
parte sería 3.3 333 333 hasta el
infinito así que yo creo que nuestro 3.3
va a estar más o menos por acá este
estrés y esto de aquí es 3.3 yo creo que
ahorita mejor pongo las etiquetas en los
números de esta recta numérica este es
uno éste es 2 aquí está el 3
aquí el 4 este 0 - 1 - 2 - 3 menos 4 y
menos 5 ahora continuamos con el 0 que
es uno de los números que acabamos de
escribir y el cero se encuentra justo
acá y bueno voy a poner este cero en
naranja para hacer obvio que se trata de
este cero de aquí ahora tenemos 21 entre
12 que es una fracción impropia y para
ver en dónde debemos colocarla aquí en
esta recta numérica vamos a señalar la
con este color azul para saber dónde
colocarla vamos a cambiarla como un
número mixto que es un poquito más fácil
de visualizar al menos para mí así que
12 que divide a 21
cabe una vez 21 menos 12 va a ser bueno
aquí podemos tomar prestado una decena
del 2 para transformar este 1 en un 11
si toma prestado del 2 el 12 transforma
en 1 y este uno de aquí se transforma en
11 lo único que estamos haciendo es
reagrupar las cantidades 11 menos 291
menos uno es cero tenemos un residuo de
9 así que esto escrito como un número
mixto es un entero y 9 12 ambos tenemos
12 12 ambos aquí y además tenemos 9
doceavos y antes de escribir esto
podemos simplificarlo todavía un poco
más incluso pudimos simplificar esto
directamente ya que 21 y 12 son
divisibles entre 3 pero bueno ahora
podemos simplificar esta parte de los 9
12 a 2 dividimos el numerador y el
denominador entre 3 y nos queda un
entero tres cuartos
como les decía pude haber simplificado
esta fracción desde el inicio antes de
ponerme a hacer la división 21 dividido
entre 3 es igual a 7
se dividido entre 3 es igual a 4 así que
esto es lo mismo que 7 cuartos y si
vemos 4 que divide a 7 el 4 cabe en el 7
una vez 74 va a ser igual a 3 nos queda
un entero tres cuartos lo mismo que acá
y ahora regresamos a ver en donde lo
podemos colocar pues es un entero y tres
cuartos vamos a dividir esto en cuartos
aquí está un medio en la mitad este es
una cuarta parte dos cuartos tres
cuartos nuestro entero y tres cuartos va
a estar justo acá aquí va a nuestro 21
sobre 12 que es lo mismo que siete
cuartos y que es lo mismo que un entero
tres cuartos ahora tenemos menos 5.5
vamos a dibujarlo en magenta se me están
acabando los colores aquí bueno aquí
tenemos el menos 5 menos 5.5 va a estar
entre menos 5 y menos 6 vamos a agregar
nuestro menos 6 en esta recta numérica
para que quede bien claro esto digamos
que este es menos 6
la recta numérica va a continuar hacia
los números más pequeños no nos movemos
un poquito a la izquierda y ahora este
menos 5.5 lo vamos a poner justo entre
el menos 5 y el menos 6 aquí está el
menos 5.5
finalmente tenemos dos enteros un octavo
y voy a hacer esto en azul tenemos este
dos y luego un octavo si queremos
encontrar el lugar preciso tenemos que
dividir esto entre ocho partes iguales
dos octavos cuatro octavos y seis
octavos así que un octavo va a estar más
o menos por acá esto de aquí es dos
enteros y un octavo
y aquí hemos dibujado más o menos la
posición de cada uno de estos números y
no es necesario dibujar la ubicación
exacta de cada número si los queremos
ordenar pero tampoco nos va a estorbar
el conocer exactamente en dónde se
ubican cuando los estamos ordenando y ya
los tenemos ordenados en esta recta
numérica y el orden es menos 5.5 es el
más pequeño luego le sigue menos 5
después el 0 le sigue un medio positivo
después 21 sobre 12 después 2 y un
octavo y finalmente el más grande es 3.3
y con esto terminamos